I just want to say congratulations to
tonight's winners thank you so much for
your beautiful films but before you
leave here tonight I ask you to think
just for a moment about what you have
received and what you still have yet to
give because most of all most of us
tonight
will ask you I want you to believe not
only in what's in you but what you can
do do me a favor grab your neighbors
hand right now all right here is our
task to believe that together your
generation will share an awesome journey
with the same sense of wonder and
enchantment enchantment that first touch
all of us as kids to believe that you
can help lift up so many through the
power of film and to take us places that
many of us never even imagined and only
you to dream of and to believe that
because of your creativity and
conscience someone somewhere will see
their own reflection in your vision
because of your gift and the gift of the
person you're holding someone somewhere
will stand a little bit taller think a
little bit differently about their
neighbor walk a difficult road with more
certainty winners all yours is a gift
not a gift to display on the mantle or
just to get dust on the trophy case but
a gift that you have to you must share
with the world Student Academy Award
recipients here is your challenge and
here is your charge to go forth and
light up the world every single dark
place you have to go light it up so I
want to thank you all for joining us in
this incredible celebration god bless
you good night and get your lights ready
[Applause]